Let's talk about "The Flight Attendant."
Everybody loves the show.
It's such a big hit.
(audience cheering)
It really came outta the gate hot.
It connected with people.
What can they expect from this season?
Well, I don't wanna give it all the way,
but everything is heightened.
The comedy, the drama, the thriller, everything.
And season one
Megan committed espio-nage
with the North Koreans.
(Drew and Rosie laughing)
By the way, that would be a cut print moving on.
I love espio-nage.
That was the best line reading ever.
And so now she's on the run,
because she knows that the North Koreans wanna murder her
and the FBI and the CIA want to arrest her
and bring her back to the States for high treason.
I mean, just a day in a life.
Yeah.
But on another note,
you and your husband were gonna get engaged,
and there's a story about the ring?
Yes, it was after Sandy, Hurricane Sandy,
he was stuck in a studio.
He's a painter, and an artist, and a graphic designer.
Sexy.
Mhmm.
So I kept telling him to come home.
And by the time it was too late,
so I didn't know what was happening to him.
He didn't know what was happening to me.
The next morning he comes home,
and we're in the backyard in our pajamas,
and he just started crying.
I go, "Babe, I'm okay."
And he goes, "No," and he got on his knees.
I went, "Oh my God," and he proposed to me.
And he goes, "Could you say yes?
My knees are killing me."
And I said, "Yes, yes, yes."
And he goes, "I don't have a ring."
And I go, "Okay, how much were you gonna spend on it?"
And he says, "That's rude."
I said, "I'm just asking you
how much are you gonna spend on it?"
And he told me the amount, I go,
"Okay, I'd rather have a new kitchen."
(audience laughing and clapping)
Again, I have to high-five you.
I love that, I love that, I love that.
There's also one other story I have to ask you about,
something about strong kissing.
Oh, that's so embarrassing.
I love it, please tell me.
Okay.
When I was younger, the boys didn't look at me,
you know, until these came.
(Rosie and Drew laughing)
Oh, men.
And so I used to practice hickeys
on my arm just in case.
You know, you gotta be ready!
You gotta be ready!
I love hickeys.
You do?
I love a hickey so much.
I really do, I hope my hickey days are not over.
The not getting caught.
The knowing it's there.
The moment you know it's going too far and you're like,
"That's gonna leave a mark."
But it's so fun!
That's weird.
(audience laughing)
So I used to watch, I loved classic movies.
TCM I love, right?
(audience clapping softly)
Old films, love it.
The best.
The best, yes.
Yay, for classic movies.
And you know how they kiss it's like, and they go in.
So when I kissed my first guy, I went in hard, right?
And he didn't say anything, he went with it.
So every boy I kissed after that,
I would smother him, and like be really forceful,
and really hard and like (breathes heavily).
And then, this one guy (laughs)
who I really, really liked, he went,
"Rose, Rose, Rose, calm down."
I said, "What?"
He goes, "You're kissing like you're in a movie."
I go, "Yeah."
And he goes, "That's not the way it's done."
I go, "No?"
He goes, "It's soft."
And I go, "I know."
He goes, "No, you don't."
And he kissed me softly and I went,
"Wow." (sighs)
Never kissed hard again.
Well, I love these stories.
I love, love, I love kissing.
I love engagements, and new kitchens, and all of the thing.
(upbeat music)